[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF DEAN: I'm excited to
be here today to tell you
about how I see deep
learning and how
it can be used to solve some of
the really challenging problems
that the world is facing.
And I should point out
that I'm presenting
the work of many, many
different people at Google.
So this is a broad perspective
of a lot of the research
that we're doing.
It's not purely my work.
So first, I'm sure you
may have all noticed,
but machine learning is
growing in importance.
There's a lot more emphasis
on machine learning research.
There's a lot more uses
of machine learning.
This is a graph showing
how many Arxiv papers--
Arxiv is a preprint
hosting service
for all kinds of
different research.
And this is the
subcategories of it
that are related to
machine learning.
And what you see is that,
since 2009, we've actually
been growing the number of
papers posted at a really
fast exponential rate, actually
faster than the Moore's Law
growth rate of computational
power that we got so nice
and used to for 40 years
but it's now slowed down.
So we've replaced the nice
growth in computing performance
with growth in people
generating ideas, which is nice.
And deep learning is
this particular form
of machine learning.
It's actually a
rebranding in some sense
of a very old set of
ideas around creating
artificial neural networks.
These are these collections of
simple trainable mathematical
units organized in layers where
the higher layers typically
build higher levels
of abstraction
based on things that the
lower layers are learning.
And you can train these
things end to end.
And the algorithms that
underlie a lot of the work
that we're doing
today actually were
developed 35, 40 years ago.
In fact, my colleague
Geoff Hinton
just won the Turing Award this
year along with Yann LeCun
and Yoshua Bengio
for a lot of the work
that they did over the
past 30 or 40 years.
And really the
ideas are not new.
But what's changed is we got
amazing results 30 or 40 years
ago on toyish
problems but didn't
have the computational resources
to make these approaches work
on real large scale problems.
But starting about
eight or nine years ago,
we started to have enough
computation to really make
these approaches work well.
And so what are things-- think
of a neural net as something
that can learn really
complicated functions that
map from input to output.
Now that sounds
kind of abstract.
You think of functions as like
y equals x squared or something.
But really these functions
can be very complicated
and can learn from
very raw forms of data.
So you can take the
pixels of an image
and train a neural
net to predict
what is in the image as a
categorical label like that's
a leopard.
That's one of my
vacation photos.
From audio wave
forms, you can learn
to predict a transcript
of what is being said.
How cold is it outside?
You can learn to take input
in one language-- hello,
how are you--
and predict the output being
that sentence translated
into another language.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
You can even do more
complicated things
like take the pixels of an
image and create a caption that
describes the image.
It's not just category.
It's like a simple sentence.
A cheetah lying on top of a
car, which is kind of unusual
anyway.
Your priority for that
should be pretty low.
And in the field
of computer vision,
we've made great strides
thanks to neural nets.
In 2011, the Stanford
ImageNet contest,
which is a contest
held every year,
the winning entry did
not use neural nets.
That was the last year.
The winning entry did
not use neural nets.
They got 26% error.
And that won the contest.
We know this task--
it's not a trivial task.
So humans themselves
have about 5%
error, because you
have to distinguish
among 1,000 different
categories of things
including like a picture of
a dog, you have to say which
of 40 breeds of dog is it.
So it's not a completely
trivial thing.
And in 2016, for example, the
winning entry got 3% error.
So this is just a
huge fundamental leap
in computer vision.
You know, computers
went from basically not
being able to see in 2011 to
now we can see pretty darn well.
And that has huge ramifications
for all kinds of things
in the world not
just computer science
but like the application of
machine learning and computing
to perceiving the
world around us.
OK.
So the rest of
this talk I'm going
to frame in a way of-- but
in 2008, the US National
Academy of Engineering
published this list of 14
grand engineering challenges
for the 21st century.
And they got together
a bunch of experts
across lots of
different domains.
And they all
collectively came up
with this list of
14 things, which
I think you can agree
these are actually
pretty challenging problems.
And if we made progress
on all of them,
the world would be
a healthier place.
We'd have a safer place.
We'd have more
scientific discovery.
All these things are
important problems.
And so given the limited
time, what I'm going to do
is talk about the
ones in boldface.
And we have projects in Google
Research that are focused
on all the ones listed in red.
But I'm not going to talk
about the other ones.
And so that's kind of the
tour of the rest of the talk.
We're just going to
dive in and off we go.
I think we start with
restoring and improving
urban infrastructure.
Right.
We know cities were designed--
the basic structure of cities
has been designed
quite some time ago.
But there's some
changes that we're
on the cusp of that are going to
really dramatically change how
we might want to design cities.
And, in particular,
autonomous vehicles
are on the verge of
commercial practicality.
This is from our Waymo
colleagues, part of Alphabet.
They've been doing work in
this space for almost a decade.
And the basic problem
of an autonomous vehicle
is you have to perceive
the world around you
from raw sensory inputs,
things like light [INAUDIBLE],,
and cameras, and radar,
and other kinds of things.
And you want to build a model
of the world and the objects
around you and understand
what those objects are.
Is that a pedestrian
or a light pole?
Is it a car that's moving?
What is it?
And then also be able to predict
both a short time from now,
like where is that car
going to be in one second,
and then make a set of
decisions about what actions
you want to take to
accomplish the goals,
get from A to B without
having any trouble.
And it's really thanks
to deep learning vision
based algorithms and fusing
of all the sensor data
that we can actually
build maps of the world
like this that
are understandings
of the environment
around us and actually
have these things operate
in the real world.
This is not some
distant far off dream.
Waymo is actually
operating about 100 cars
with passengers in the
back seat and no safety
drivers in the front seat in
the Phoenix, Arizona area.
And so this is a
pretty strong sense
that this is pretty
close to reality.
Now Arizona is one of the easier
self-driving car environments.
It's like it never rains.
It's too hot so there aren't
that many pedestrians.
The streets are very wide.
The other drivers are very slow.
Downtown San
Francisco is harder,
but this is a sign that
it's not that far off.
Obviously, a vision
works, it's easier
to build robots that can
do things in the world.
If you can't see, it's
really hard to do things.
But if you can start to
see, you can actually
have practical
robotics things that
use computer vision to then
make decisions about how
they should act in the world.
So this is a video of a
bunch of robots practicing
picking things up, and then
dropping them and picking
more things up, and essentially
trying to grasp things.
And it turns out that one
nice thing about robots
is you can actually
collect the sensor data
and pool the experience
of many robots,
and then collectively train on
their collective experience,
and then get a
better model of how
to actually grasp things,
and then push that out
to the robots.
And then the next
day they can all
practice with a slightly
better grasping model,
because unlike
humans that you plop
on the carpet in
your living room,
they don't get to
pool their experience.
OK.
So in 2015, the success rate
on a particular grasping task
of grasping objects that a
robot has never seen before
was about 65%.
When we use this
kind of arm farm--
that's what that
thing is called.
I wanted to call it the
armpit, but I was overruled.
Basically, by collecting
a lot of experience,
we were actually able to get
a pretty significant boost
in grasp success
rate, up to 78%.
And then with further work on
algorithms and more refinement
of the approach, we're now
able to get a 96% grasp success
right.
So this is pretty good
progress in three years.
We've gone from a third of the
time you fail to pick something
up, which is very hard to
actually string together
a whole sequence of things and
actually have robots actually
do things in the real world, to
grasping almost working quite
reliably.
So that's exciting.
We've also been
doing a lot of work
on how do we get robots
to do things more easily.
Rather than having them
practice themselves,
maybe we can demonstrate
things to them.
So this is one of our
AI residents doing work.
They also do fantastic
machine learning research,
but they also film demonstration
videos for these robots.
And what you see here
is a simulated robot
trying to emulate from the
raw pixels of the video what
it's seeing.
And on the right, you see a
few demonstrations of pouring
and the robot using
those video clips,
five or 10 seconds of
someone pouring something,
and some reinforcement learning
based trials to attempt
to learn to pour on its own.
After 15 trials and about
15 minutes of training,
it's able to pour
that well, I would
say like at the level
of a four-year-old
not an eight-year-old.
But that's actually much--
in 15 minutes of
effort, it's able to get
to that level of success,
which is a pretty big deal.
OK.
One of the other areas that
was in the grand challenges
was advanced health informatics.
I think you saw in
the keynote yesterday
the work on lung cancer.
We've also been
doing a lot of work
on an eye disease called
diabetic retinopathy, which
is the fastest growing cause
of blindness in the world.
There's 115 million people
in the world with diabetes.
And each of them ideally
would be screened every year
to see if they have
diabetic retinopathy, which
is a degenerative eye disease
that if you catch in time
it's very treatable.
But if you don't
catch it in time,
you can suffer full or
partial vision loss.
And so it's really
important that we
be able to screen everyone
that is at risk for this.
And yeah.
Regular screening.
And that's the
image that you get
to see as an ophthalmologist.
And in India, for
example, there's
a shortage of more than
100,000 eye doctors
to do the necessary amount
of screening of this disease.
And so 45% of patients
suffer vision loss
before they're diagnosed,
which is tragic,
because it's a completely
preemptible thing if you
catch it in time.
And basically, the way an
ophthalmologist looks at this
is they look at these
images and they grade it
on a five point scale, one,
two, three, four, or five,
looking for things like
these little hemorrhages
that you see on the
right hand side.
And it's a little subjective.
So if you ask two
ophthalmologists
to grade the same image, they
agree on the score, one, two,
three, four, or five,
60% of the time.
And if you ask the
same ophthalmologist
to grade the same image
a few hours later,
they agree with themselves
65% of the time.
And this is why second opinions
are useful in medicine,
because some of these things
are actually quite subjective.
And it's actually a big
deal because the difference
between a two and a three
is actually go away and come
back in a year versus
we better get you
into the clinic next week.
Nonetheless, this is actually
a computer vision problem.
And so instead of having a
classification of a thousand
general categories
of dogs and leopards,
you can actually just have
five categories of the five
levels of diabetic
retinopathy and train
the model on eye images
and an assessment
of what the score should be.
And if you do that,
you can actually
get the images labeled by
several ophthalmologists, six
or seven, so that you reduce
the variance that you already
see between ophthalmologists
assessing the same image.
Five of them say it's two.
Two of them say it's a three,
it's probably more like a two
than a three.
And if you do that,
then you can essentially
get a model that is on
par or slightly better
than the average board
certified ophthalmologist that's
set at doing this
task, which is great.
This is work published
at the end of 2016
by my colleagues in "JAMA,"
which is a top medical journal.
We wanted to do
even better though.
So it turns out you can
actually, instead of--
you can get the images labeled
by retinal specialists who
have more training in
retinal eye disease.
And instead of getting
independent assessments,
you get three
retinal specialists
in a room for each image.
And you essentially
say, OK, you all
have to come up with
an adjudicated number.
What number do you
agree on for each image?
And if you do that,
then you can train
on the output of this consensus
of three retinal specialists.
And you actually
now have a model
that is on par with
retinal specialists, which
is the gold standard
of care in this area,
rather than the
not as good model
trained on an
ophthalmologist's opinion.
And so this is
something that we've
seen born out where you have
really good high quality
training data and
you can actually
then train a model
on that and get
the effects of retinal
specialists into the model.
But the other neat thing
is you can actually have
completely new discoveries.
So someone new joined the
ophthalmology research team
as a warm up exercise
to understand
how our tools worked.
Lily Peng, who is on
the stage yesterday,
said, oh, why don't
you go see if you
can predict age and gender
from the retinal image
just to see if the machine
learning pipeline--
a person could get that machine
learning pipeline going?
And ophthalmologists
can't predict gender
from an eye image.
They don't know how to do that.
And so Lilly thought the
average that you see on this
should be no better
than flipping a coin.
You see a 0.5.
And the person
went away and they
said, OK, I've got it done.
My AUC is 0.7.
And Lilly is like,
hmm, that's weird.
Go check everything
and come back.
And so they came
back and they said,
OK, I've made a
few improvements.
It's now 0.8.
That got people excited
because all of a sudden
we realized you can
actually predict
a whole bunch of interesting
things from a retinal image.
In particular, you
can actually detect
someone's self-reported sex.
And you can predict a
whole bunch of other things
like their age, things about
their systolic and diastolic
blood pressure, their
hemoglobin level.
And it turns out you combine
those things together
and you can get a prediction of
someone's cardiovascular risk
at the same level of accuracy
that normally a much more
invasive blood test where you
have to draw blood, send it off
to the lab, wait 24 hours,
get the lab test back.
Now you can just do that
with a retinal image.
So there's real hope that
this could be a new thing
that if you go to
the doctor you'll get
a picture of your eye taken.
And we'll have a longitudinal
history of your eye
and be able to learn
new things from it.
So we're pretty
excited about that.
A lot of the grand challenges
were around understanding
molecules and chemistry better.
One is engineer
better medicines.
But this work that
I'm going to show you
might apply to some
of these other things.
So one of the things quantum
chemists want to be able to do
is predict properties
of molecules.
You know, will this thing
bind to this other thing?
Is it toxic?
What are its quantum properties?
And the normal way
they do this is they
have a really computationally
expensive simulator.
And you plug in this
molecule configuration.
You wait about an hour.
And at the end of that you get
the output, which says, OK,
here are the things
the simulator told you.
So it turns out-- and
it's a slow process.
You can't consider that
many different molecules
like you might like to.
It turns out you can
use the simulator
as a teacher for a neural net.
So you can do that.
And then all of a sudden
you have a neural net
that can basically learn to
do what the simulator can
do but way faster.
And so now you
have something that
is about 300,000 times faster.
And you can't
distinguish the accuracy
of the output of the neural
net versus the simulator.
And so that's a completely
game changing thing
if you're a quantum chemist.
All of a sudden your tool
is sped up by 300,000 times.
And all of a sudden
that means you
can do a very different
kind of science.
You can say, oh, while
I'm going to lunch
I should probably screen
100 million molecules.
And when I come
back, I'll have 1,000
that might be interesting.
So that's a pretty
interesting trend.
And I think it's one
that will play out
in lots and lots of
different scientific fields
or engineering fields
where you have this really
expensive simulator
but you can actually
learn to approximate it with
a much cheaper neural net
or machine learning
based model and get
a simulator that's much faster.
OK.
Engineer the tools of
scientific discovery.
I have a feeling this
14th one was just
kind of a vague catch all thing
that the panel of experts that
was convened decided should do.
But it's pretty clear that
if machine learning is going
to be a big part of scientific
discovery and engineering,
we want good tools to express
machine learning algorithms.
And so that's the
motivation for why
we created TensorFlow is we
wanted to be to have tools
that we could use to express
our own machine learning ideas
and share them with
the rest of the world,
and have other researchers
exchange machine learning ideas
and put machine learning models
into practice in products
and other environments.
And so we released
this at the end of 2015
with this Apache 2.0 license.
And basically it has this
graph based computational model
that you can then optimize with
a bunch of traditional compiler
optimizations and it
then can be mapped
onto a variety of
different devices.
So you can run the
same computation
on CPUs or GPUs or our TPUs
that I'll tell you about in
a minute.
Eager Mode makes this graph
implicit rather than explicit,
which is coming
in TensorFlow 2.0.
And the community
seems to have adopted
TensorFlow reasonably well.
And we've been excited by
all the different things
that we've seen other
people do, both in terms
of contributing to the
core TensorFlow system
but also making use of it
to do interesting things.
And so it's got some pretty
good engagement kinds of stats.
50 million downloads for a
fairly obscure programming
packages is a fair
number that seems
like a good mark of traction.
And we've seen people do things.
So I mentioned this in
the keynote yesterday.
I like this one.
It's basically a company
building fitness center
for cows so you can tell
which of your 100 dairy cows
is behaving a little
strangely today.
There is a research team at
Penn State and the International
Institute of Tropical
Agriculture in Tanzania
that is building a machine
learning model that
can run on device on a phone in
the middle of a cassava field
without any network
connection to actually detect
does this cassava
plant have disease
and how should I treat it.
I think this is a
good example of how
we want machine
learning to run in lots
and lots of environments.
Lots of places in
the world sometimes
you have connectivity.
Sometimes you don't.
A lot of cases you want
it to run on device.
And it's really going
to be the future.
You're going to have machine
learning models running
on tiny microcontrollers, all
kinds of things like this.
OK.
I'm going to use the remaining
time to take you on a tour
through some researchy projects
and then sketch how they might
fit together in the future.
So I believe what we want is
we want bigger machine learning
models than we have today.
But in order to
make that practical,
we want models that
are sparsely activated.
So think of a giant model, maybe
with 1,000 different pieces.
But you activate 20 or 30 of
those pieces for any given
example, rather than the
entire set of 1,000 pieces.
We know this is a property
that real organisms have
in their neural systems is
most of their neural capacity
is not active at
any given point.
That's partly how they're
so power efficient.
Right.
So some work we did a couple
of years ago at this point
is what we call a sparsely
gated mixture of experts layer.
And the essential idea is
these pink rectangles here
are normal neural net layers.
But between a couple
of neural net layers,
we're going to insert
another collection
of tiny little neural
nets that we call experts.
And we're going to have
a gating network that's
going to learn to activate
just a few of those.
It's going to learn
which of those experts
is most effective for a
particular kind of example.
And the expert might
have a lot of parameters.
It might be pretty large
matrix of parameters.
And we're going to
have a lot of them.
So we have in total eight
billion-ish parameters.
But we're going to activate
just a couple of the experts
on any given example.
And you can see that when
you learn to route things,
you try to learn to
use the expert that
is most effective at
this particular example.
And when you send it
to multiple experts,
that gives you a signal to
train the routing network,
the gating network so that it
can learn that this expert is
really good when you're
talking about language that
is about innovation
and researchy things
like you see on
the left hand side.
And this center expert
is really good at talking
about playing a leading
role and central role.
And the one on the right
is really good at kind
of quicky adverby things.
And so they actually do
develop very different kinds
of expertise.
And the nice thing
about this is if you
compare this in a translation
task with the bottom row,
you can essentially get
a significant improvement
in translation accuracy.
That's the blue score there.
So one blue point improvement
is a pretty significant thing.
We really look like one
blue point improvements.
And because it has all
this extra capacity,
we can actually make the
sizes of the pink layers
smaller than they were
in the original model.
And so we can actually
shrink the amount
of computation used per word
by about a factor of two,
so 50% cheaper inference.
And the training time goes
way down because we just
have all this extra capacity.
And it's easier to train a
model with a lot of parameters.
And so we have about
1/10 the training cost
in terms of GPU days.
OK.
We've also been
doing a lot of work
on AutoML, which is this
idea behind automating some
of the machine learning
tasks that a machine learning
researcher or engineer does.
And the idea behind
AutoML is currently
you think about solving a
machine learning problem
where you have some data.
You have some computation.
And you have an ML
expert sit down.
And they do a bunch
of experiments.
And they kind of
stir it all together
and run lots of GPU
days worth of effort.
And you hopefully
get a solution.
So what if we could
turn this into using
more computation to replace
some of the experimentation
that a machine learning--
someone with a lot of
machine learning experience
would actually do?
And one of the decisions that
a machine learning expert makes
is what architecture, what
neural network structure
makes sense for this problem.
You know, should I use a 13
layer model or a nine layer
model?
Should it have three by three
or five by five filters?
Should it have skip
connections or not?
And so if you're willing to
say let's try to take this
up a level and do
some meta learning,
then we can basically have a
model that generates models
and then try those models on the
problem we actually care about.
So the basic iteration
of meta learning here
is we're going to have a
model generating model.
We're going to
generate 10 models.
We're going to train
each of those models.
And we're going to see
how well they each work
on the problem we care about.
And we're going to use the loss
or the accuracy of those models
as a reinforcement learning
signal for the model generating
model so that we can steer away
from models that didn't seem
to work very well
and towards models
that seem to work better.
And then we just repeat a lot.
And when we repeat a
lot, we essentially
get more and more
accurate models over time.
And it works.
And it produces models that
are a little strange looking.
Like they're a little
more unstructured
than you might think
of a model that a human
might have designed.
So here we have all these
crazy skip connections.
But they're analogous
to some of the ideas
that machine learning
researchers themselves
have come up with in.
For example, the
resonant architecture
has a more structured
style of skip connection.
But the basic idea is
you want information
to be able to flow more directly
from the input to the output
without going through as many
intermediate computational
layers.
And the system seems
to have developed
that intuition itself.
And the nice thing is
these models actually
work pretty well.
So if you look at
this graph, accuracy
is on the y-axis for
the ImageNet problem.
And computational
cost of the models,
which are represented by
dots here, is on the x-axis.
So generally, you
see this trend where
if you have a more
computationally expensive
model, you generally
get higher accuracy.
And each of these
black dots here
is something that was a
significant amount of effort
by a bunch of top computer
vision researchers or machine
learning researchers
that then they
published and advanced the
state of the art at the time.
And so if you apply AutoML
to this problem, what you see
is that you actually exceed
the frontier of the hand
generated models that the
community has come up with.
And you do this both
at the high end,
where you care
most about accuracy
and don't care as much
about computational costs
so you can get a model
that's slightly more accurate
with less computational cost.
And at the low end,
you can get a model
that's significantly more
accurate for a very small
amount of computational cost.
And that, I think, is a
pretty interesting result.
It says that we should really
let computers and machine
learning researchers
work together
to develop the best models
for these kinds of problems.
And we've turned
this into a product.
So we have Cloud AutoML
as a Cloud product.
And you can try that
on your own problem.
So if you were
maybe a company that
doesn't have a lot of
machine learning researchers,
or machine learning
engineers yourselves,
you can actually just
take a bunch of images in
and categories of things
you want to do-- maybe you
have pictures from
your assembly line.
You want to predict what
part is this image of.
You can actually get a high
quality model for that.
And we've extended this to
things more than just vision.
So you can do videos, and
language, and translation.
And more recently we've
introduced something
that allows you to
predict relational data
from other relational data.
You want to predict will this
customer buy something given
their past orders or something.
We've also obviously continued
research in the AutoML field.
So we've got some work looking
at the use of evolution
rather than reinforcement
learning for the search,
learning the
optimization update rule,
learning the nonlinearity
function rather than just
assuming we should
use [INAUDIBLE]
or some other kind of
activation function.
We've actually got some
work on incorporating
both inference latency
and the accuracy.
Let's say you want a
really good model that has
to run in seven milliseconds.
We can find the
most accurate model
that will run in your time
budget allowed by using a more
complicated reward function.
We can learn how to augment
data so that you can stretch
the amount of label data
you have in interesting ways
more effectively than
handwritten data augmentation.
And we can explore
lots of architectures
to make this whole search
process a bit more efficient.
OK.
But it's clear if we're going
to try these approaches,
we're going to need more
computational power.
And I think one of the
truisms of machine learning
over the last decade or
so is more computational
power tends to
get better results
when you have enough data.
And so it's really
nice that deep learning
is this really
broadly useful tool
across so many different
problem domains,
because that means you can start
to think about specializing
hardware for deep
learning but have
it apply to many, many things.
And so there are two properties
that deep learning algorithms
tend to have.
One is they're very tolerant
of reduced precision.
So if you do calculations to
one decimal digit of precision,
that's perfectly fine with
most of these algorithms.
You don't need six or
seven digits of precision.
And the other thing
is that they are all--
all these algorithms I've
shown you are made up
of a handful of specific
operations, things like matrix
multiplies, vector dot
products, essentially
dense linear algebra.
So if you can build
machines, computers,
that are really good at reduced
precision dense linear algebra,
then you can accelerate lots
of these machine learning
algorithms quite a lot compared
to more general purpose
computers that have
general purpose CPUs that
can run all kinds
of things or even
GPUs which tend to be somewhat
good at this but tend to have,
for example, higher precision
than you might want.
So we started to
think about building
specialized hardware when
I did this kind of thought
exercise in 2012.
We were starting to
see the initial success
of deep neural nets
for speech recognition
and for image
recognition and starting
to think about how
would we deploy
these in some of our products.
And so there was
this scary moment
where we realized that if speech
started to work really well,
and at that time
we couldn't run it
on device because
the devices didn't
have enough
computational power, what
if 100 million users started
talking to their phones
for three minutes a day, which
is not implausible if speech
starts to work a lot better.
And if we were running
the speech models on CPUs,
we need to double the number
of computers in Google data
centers, which is slightly
terrifying to launch
one feature in one product.
And so we started to think
about building these specialized
processors for the deep learning
algorithms we wanted to run
and TPU V1 has been
in production use
since 2015 was really the
outcome of that thought
exercise.
And it's in production use
based on every query you do,
on every translation you
do, speech processing, image
crossing, AlphaGo use
a collection of these.
This is the actual racks
of machines that were
competed in the AlphaGo match.
You can see the
little Go board we've
commemorated with on the side.
And then we started to tackle
the bigger problem of not just
inference, which is we
already have a trained model
and you just want to apply
it, but how do you actually do
training in an accelerated way.
And so the second
version of TPUs
are for training and inference.
And that's one of
the TPU devices,
which has four chips on it.
This is TPU V3, which
also has four chips on it.
It's got water cooling.
So it's slightly scary to
have water in your computers,
but we do.
And then we designed
these systems
to be configured together
into larger configurations we
call pods.
So this is a TPU V2 pod.
This is a bigger TPU V3
pod with water cooling.
You can actually see one of the
racks of this in the machine
learning dome.
And really these things
actually do provide
a lot of computational power.
Individual devices
with the four chips
are up to 420 teraflops have
a fair amount of memory.
And then the actual
pods themselves are
up to 100 petaflops of compute.
This is a pretty substantial
amount of compute
and really lets you
very quickly try machine
learning research experiments,
train very large production
models on large data
sets, and these are also
now available through
our cloud products.
As of yesterday, I think we
announced them to be in beta.
One of the keys to
performance here
is the network interconnect
between the chips in the pods
is actually your
super high speed 2D
mesh with wrap around links.
That's why it's toroidal.
And that means you can
essentially program this thing
as if it's a single computer.
And the software
underneath the covers
takes care of distributing
the computation appropriately
and can do very fast all
reduced kind of operations
and broadcast operations.
And so, for example, you
can use a full TPU V2 pod
to train ImageNet in 7.9 minutes
versus the same problem using
eight GPUs.
You get 27 times faster
training at lower cost.
The V3 pod is actually
even substantially larger.
You can train an
ImageNet model in scratch
in less than two minutes,
more than a million images
per second in training, which is
essentially the entire ImageNet
data set every second.
And you can train very
large BERT language models,
for example, as I was
discussing on stage
in the keynote yesterday
in about 76 minutes
on a fairly large corpus of data
which normally would take days.
And so that really helps
make our researchers
and ML production
systems more productive
by being able to
experiment more quickly.
If you can run an experiment
in two minutes, that's
a very different kind of
science and engineering
you do than if that
same experiment would
take you a day and a half.
Right.
You just think about
running more experiments,
trying more things.
And we have lots of
models already available.
OK.
So let's take some of
the ideas we talked about
and think about how
they might fit together.
So I said we want these
really large models
but have them be
sparsely activated.
I think one of the things we're
doing wrong in machine learning
is we tend to train a
machine learning model
to do a single thing.
And then we have a
different problem.
We tend to train a different
model to do that other thing.
And I think really we should
be thinking about how can we
train models that
do many, many things
and leverage the
expertise that they have
in doing many things to then
be able to take on a new task
and learn to do that new task
more quickly and with less
data.
This is, essentially,
multi task learning.
But often multi task
learning in practice today
means three or four
or five tasks, not
thousands or millions.
I think we really want to be
thinking bigger and bolder
about really doing in the limit
one model for all of the things
we care about.
And obviously,
we're going to try
to train this large model
using fancy ML hardware.
OK.
So how might this look?
So I imagine we've
trained a model
on a bunch of different tasks.
And it's learned these
different components,
which can be sometimes shared
across different tasks,
sometimes independent,
specialized
for a particular task.
And now a new task comes along.
So with the AutoML style
reinforcement learning,
we should be able to use an
RL logarithm to find pathways
through this model
that actually get us
into a pretty good
state for that new task,
because it hopefully has some
commonalities with other things
we've already learned.
And then we might have some way
to add capacity to the system
so that for a task where we
really care about accuracy,
we can add a bit of capacity and
start to use that for this task
and have that pathway be more
specialized for that task
and therefore hopefully
more accurate.
And I think that's an
interesting direction to go in.
How can we think more about
building a system like that
than the current kind of
models we have today where
we tend to fully activate the
entire model for every example
and tend to have them
just for a single task?
OK.
I want to close on how we should
be thinking about using machine
learning and all
the different places
that we might consider using it.
And I think one of
the things that I'm
really proud of as a company
is that last year we published
a set of principles
by which we think
about how we're going
to use machine learning
for different things.
And I think these
seven things when
we look at using machine
learning in any of our products
or settings we think carefully
about how are we actually
fulfilling these
principles by using
machine learning in this way.
And I think there's more on
the actual principles website
that you can go find, but I
think this is really, really
important.
And I'll point out that
some of these things
are evolving research
areas as well as principles
that we want to apply.
So for example, number two,
avoid creating or reinforcing
unfair bias.
And bias in machine
learning models
is a very real problem that you
get from a variety of sources.
Could be you have
biased training data.
Could be you're training
on real world data
and the world does
itself is biased
in ways that we don't want.
And so there is research that
we can apply and extend in
how do we reduce
bias or eliminate it
from machine learning models.
And so this is an example
of some of the work
we've been doing on
bias and fairness.
But what we try to do
in our use of ML models
is apply the best
known practices
for our actual
production use but also
advance the state of the art in
understanding bias and fairness
and making it better.
And so with that, in conclusion,
deep neural nets and machine
learning are really
tackling some of the world's
great challenges I think.
I think we're really making
progress in a number of areas.
There's a lot of
interesting problems
to tackle and to still work on.
And they're going to affect
not just computer science.
Right.
We're affecting many, many
aspects of human endeavor
like medicine, science,
other kinds of things.
And so I think it's a
great responsibility
that we have to make sure
that we do these things right
and to continue to push
for the state of the art
and apply it to great things.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]